medieval art of animals
often looked a little different from the
real world species
and this mismatch was compounded with
any animal the artist had clearly
never seen before european texts from
this period
are full of hilarious attempts to depict
far-off species
so let's take a look at some of the most
inaccurate bearing in mind it would be
difficult to know what say
an elephant would look like if you'd
never seen one before
and speaking of elephants they're a good
place to start when it comes to
inaccurate depictions medieval artists
seem to struggle with the concept of the
trunk especially
often rendering it in bizarre ways many
illustrations also depict elephants
supporting entire stone castles on their
backs
spurring from myths elephants were
mighty enough to carry around entire
buildings
this is of course incorrect
large african animal medieval artist
struggled to portray accurately as the
hippopotamus
possibly to an even greater extent than
the elephant most illustrations of
hippos from the era are way off with an
assortment of aquatic traits like tails
and dorsal fins actual hippos don't
possess
other depictions almost make hippos look
like strange horses
perhaps due to misunderstandings
surrounding the animal's name which
means
river horse in latin up next we have the
giraffe
an animal medieval artist portrayed with
less frequency than the hippo or
elephant
compared to the hippo at the very least
some pieces of art actually get the
giraffe's general appearance
mostly right emphasizing the long neck
well
most of the time moving on to african
predators we have the hyena
an animal with rather inconsistent
interpretations across different
paintings
in some illustrations the hyena features
horns and
almost resembles a carnivorous cow while
others are more dog-like
one curious trend is that in many images
hyenas appear to be consuming the dead
this is because of a common myth that
the animals dug up cemeteries to eat
human remains
a concept which is inaccurate moving to
a different part of the world
another large predator which gets the
short end of the stick in medieval art
is the tiger
far from the massive predatory felines
of the real world medieval tigers were
small
dog-like creatures lacking the animal's
trademark stripes
strangely enough in many illustrations
the tiger is drawn looking in a mirror
this stems from a legend that a hunter
could steal a tiger's cubs if they
distracted the mother with her
reflection
as the mother would mistake it for her
cub a pretty grim legend
and one that would more than likely
result in immediate death i've tried on
a real tiger
moving on to the world of birds the
ostrich is a species medieval artists
seem to find particularly challenging
most images of ostriches lack almost all
of the animals defining features
including their long neck and flightless
nature indeed many depictions of the
ostrich just look like standard birds
another unusual trend is the ostrich of
medieval art is often shown abandoning
its egg to roast in the sun
although real ostriches do leave their
eggs exposed in ground nests
this isn't because they're neglectful
parents their eggs do just fine out in
the open
furthermore another odd trend is
illustrating the birds eating an iron
horseshoe
this comes from a myth that ostriches
could digest anything
even metal once again this is distinctly
false
another unique looking bird missing many
of its most notable features is the
pelican
which in medieval art is a short beaked
organism lacking its trademark throat
pouch
a highly unusual theme is most
depictions show pelican families eating
each other
the bizarre cannibalism comes from a
legend that pelican babies try to eat
their parents when fully grown
prompting the parents to eat them in
return this is an
obviously an accurate notion as any real
species would die in just a few
generations using such a behavioral
model
diving into the ocean the next animal
we're touching on is the whale an
aquatic leviathan which
rarely looks anything like the real
species in medieval art
in most depictions the animal looks less
like what we know of as a whale and more
like a giant
fish to the point where some versions
are even covered in fish-like scales
some whales and medieval illustrations
go a step further away from the real
animal and seem to have legs while we're
dealing with the ocean the dolphin is
another interestingly albeit incorrectly
portrayed marine mammal when it comes to
marine art
like the whale the dolphin usually just
resembles a giant slightly goofy
looking fish one aquatic organism which
deviates even further from its real-life
counterpart
however is the sea turtle which for some
reason is often portrayed as bipedal
with a massive tail
sea turtles and medieval paintings also
usually feature
curiously shaped shells and segmented
toes
one depiction of the sea turtle even
seems to look more like a hedgehog
but the artist likely hearing the animal
was armored and incorrectly assuming the
two species were equivalent
going further inland one semi-aquatic
predator medieval artist took serious
liberties with
is the crocodile with many images of the
animal looking borderline
unrecognizable to be fair some
illustrations at least look more or less
like a reptile while others really
deviate from crocodilian features
displaying hair paws bushy tails and
short doglike snouts
then again some of the drawings of
crocodiles which don't include fur
don't look all that better nearing the
end of our list
and truly veering into bizarre territory
we have the scorpion
another animal given fur and mammalian
features without any clear explanation
there's something about giving a
scorpion a non-arachnid face which makes
it look so
fundamentally absurd at least some
depictions give it more legs than a
standard quadruped
well some depictions at the very end of
our journey we have an animal you'd
never be able to identify just by
looking at medieval portrayals
the chameleon although in real life the
animal is a lizard medieval art is
sometimes portrayed
as a horse-like organism and sometimes
more like a cat
in either case one thing is for sure it
looks nothing like the animal it's based
on
the error might come from phonetic
similarities between chameleon and
leon are lion but truthfully the reason
why chameleons are so inaccurate in art
from the period
is anyone's guess and that's where our
list comes to an end
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
i have another one like it
on the strangest fictional medieval
monsters please consider subscribing and
leaving this video a like if you
appreciated the content
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you